[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans ses yeux il avait des jardins et
des châteaux de son cœur chissit des
Princess et des géau des enfants qui et
qui faisait du vélo j'avais devant
moi un homme
heureureux ah ça je voyais seent C
éclair comme de l'eau il n'était pas
pareil il brillait comme un soleil j'en
avais j'en avais j'en avais les larmes
aux yeux j'avais
découvert un homme
heureureux je pensais qu'il exagérait et
que ses a sou c'était rien que pour
m'embêter tu sais comme j'avais envie de
le tuer je dis qu'un bateau m'attendit
et puis je suis parti à pied ah il
s'était bien moquer de moi il n'y
reprprendrait
pas dans ses yeux il avait des jardins
et des châteaux de son cœur chissaient
des princesses et des j d'au des enfants
qui riaent et qui faisaient du vélo
j'avais découvert
[Musique]
unux ah ça se voyait se sentait cétait
clair comme de l'eau il n'était pas
pareil il briait comme un soleil faut
dire qu' faut dire qu' faut dire qu'il
me fascinait j'avais
découvert un homme
heureux je pensais qu'il exagéré et que
c'est celle s soulier c'était rien que
pour m'embêter tu sais tu sais comme
j'avais envie de le tuer je dis qu'un
bateau mattend et puis je suis parti à
pied oh ah c'était bien moqué de moi sûr
il n'y reprendrait pas mais quand je
suis rentré chez moi
h dans ma chambre il avait des jardins
et des châteaux de mon lit chissais des
princesses et des géau des enfants qui
riaaient et qui faisait du vélo j'étais
devenu ah
non
ah je volis je plis j'ai déclair comme
de l'É ça poussait ça poussa j'ai des
ailes à mes sabots le bonheur le bonheur
le bonheur c'est contagieux tu as devant
toi un hom
[Musique]
heure
[Applaudissements]